first of all I'd like to add my thanks
to being out burn for his very gracious
introduction it's a little humbling to
be introduced in such a personal way by
someone who's been a friend for so many
years and I would modify one statement
that Joe made I would say he was the
best team we've ever had not one of the
best and we miss him so I want to return
to the question that Joe posed at the
beginning which is what is the normal
function of ghrelin why is it why is
this hormone conserved through fish and
amphibians and and the reason that it's
a puzzle is because the knockout animals
when people knocked out the gene for
either ghrelin or the receptor in mice
it was essentially no effect on appetite
or body weight or and very slight
effects on metabolism so why is this
hormone so help so well conserved so our
approach to this we began to be
interested in this when we made goat
knockout mice having isolated and
identified the enzyme that attaches
ghrelin to determine its relevance in
vivo we collaborated with the Regeneron
company to knock out the goat gene and
and what you see here is the knockout
construct that the people at regeneron
May and and it knocks out basically the
whole gene and and they sent us the
embryonic stem cells and we made mice
and what you see here is that this is
the level of goat messenger RNA in the
stomach and it's basically undetectable
in the knockout mouse but ghrelin is
still expressed
and if one looks at plasma ghrelin
levels in the knockout mice they're
essentially undetectable in wild-type
mice the ghrelin Rises with fasting but
in the knockout mice they're not able to
make any ghrelin now ghrelin as joe said
when when we talk about when we use the
term ghrelin we're talking about asa
lated grillin but these goat knockout
mice still make the des a so form of
ghrelin and if anything that's elevated
in the plasma of these mice so we have
mice now that have a total inability to
make the active form of grilling so what
happens to their body weight well here's
the body weight of wild-type mice and
the goat knockout mice either on a child
diet or on a high-fat diet and you see
that both animals gain exactly the same
amount of weight on a high-fat diet so
the not the results with the goat
knockout are the same as that other
people had found with the ghrelin
knockout and that is that it doesn't
seem to have any in it it's not it's
certainly not required in order for
animals to consume either normal food or
calorie enriched food so since ghrelin
didn't have seemed to have anything to
do with body weight or metabolism when
animals are well fed then the question
was because maybe we're asking the wrong
question and perhaps that ghrelin is
essential when animals are starved so we
be began the studies that are outlined
on this slide and
the way we do these studies is very
important so I'll go through it in some
detail so a postdoctoral fellow in our
laboratory Tom jinyang at UNK ins ow
does takes mice and puts them in
individual cages and then he measures
their food intake for a week so he knows
how much each mouse eats every day and
then for each mouse into individually he
reduces the food intake by sixty percent
so that the mice now are only eating
forty percent of the food that they
would normally eat and it's the mice are
fed forty percent of this intake for
seven to nine days and it's very
important for the studies that you
understand that the daily regimen of
these mice the food is supplied at 6pm
each day and the mice become ravenously
hungry so both the wild-type mice and
the goat minus mice eat their entire
allotment of food within an hour so at
six o'clock they basically get one meal
and then for the rest of the 24-hour
period they're fat they're essentially
fasting and we measured their blood
glucose at five-thirty p.m. the next day
which is 22 and a half hours after
eating so the mice are chronically
calorie restricted and then they
essentially fast for 24 hours and and
when we look at the responses of the
mice first of all in terms of body way
both the wild-type and the goat minus
mice obviously lose weight on this diet
they lose about thirty percent of their
body weight but the weight reduction is
the same in the goat minus and the the
wild-type and they both lose the huge
majority of their fatness so our normal
mice have about eight percent body fat
and it's crucial to see that in order to
see the metabolic responses that i'm
going to show you they have to lose fat
so that their body fat is reduced to two
percent
so this is a very severe calorie
restriction admit it's a mimic of a
famine essentially and the animals
basically have almost no adipose tissue
mass so what happens to blood sugar and
that's where we got the first indication
of something important going on in
wild-type mice when they're put on this
calorie-restricted diet and then the
sugar is measured at five-thirty p.m.
the blood sugar Falls but then it
absolutely stabilizes over the next
seven days but in the goat not- nice the
initial fall is the same but they never
stabilize and each day the blood sugar
is progressively lower so that by the
seventh day the blood sugar is somewhere
between 10 and 20 milligrams per
deciliter and all of you should know
that that's basically not compatible
with life the animals become almost
moribund and they have to be sacrificed
so it looks like go ghrelin is necessary
in order to maintain the blood sugar
during this these times of severe
calorie restriction now what's even more
interesting is the daily pattern of
blood sugar in these animals so now
you're looking at animals that have been
calorie restricted for a week when we
and remember they were fed than previous
night at six at 6pm so now 15 hours
later at nine o'clock in the morning the
animals the knockout animals and the
wild-type animals have the same blood
sugar but then during the day when there
is really no more food left the
wild-type animals are able to maintain
their blood sugar but the goat minus
animals decline progressive
during the day and then when they're fed
at six o'clock immediately within two
hours their blood sugar goes back to
normal now if you look at the plasma
ghrelin level in wild-type mice the
ghrelin level starts out relatively low
and as the as they go through the day
without food they're ghrelin level goes
to really astronomical these are very
high ghrelin levels and then again as
soon as they're fed the gremlin goes
down of course the knockout animals
can't make any grill and so they have no
grillin during the day but their des a
so ghrelin levels parallel that of the
wild-type animals so the knockouts can
make the des acyl grillin but they can't
isolate now this is the important part
of this if you look at the plasma growth
hormone level remember ghrelin releases
growth hormone and when ghrelin goes up
in the wild-type animals growth hormone
levels climb dramatically and when
they're fed ghrelin comes down and
growth hormone immediately comes down so
there's a correlation between the rise
in plasma ghrelin and the rise in growth
hormone now the question is is this some
effect of specific effect of the goat
knockout what is it really a loss of
ghrelin so we obtained some mice that
were knocked out not in goat but in
ghrelin itself these are pre-programmed
knockout mice and the response is
exactly the same here's a these are
pre-programmed out my so they can't make
any ghrelin they've been calorie
restricted for seven days and you see
that during the day their blood sugar
Falls just like the goat knockout and
it's restored by food of course these
ghrelin knockout mice can't show the
increase in plasma ghrelin and these
mice can't make that ghrelin knockout
mice can't make des asil ghrelin either
and so they have no des asil ghrelin and
again the growth hormone
response doesn't occur if you don't have
grilling so it looks like ghrelin is
necessary in order to maintain the blood
sugar now the question is why does the
blood sugar fall during the day in the
ghrelin knockout mice so recently we've
measured the plasma lactate level so the
major substrate for glucose production
in the liver is lactate which is
generated in muscle and what you can see
here is that in the goat knockout
animals progressively during the day the
plasma lactate level Falls and then it's
restored as soon as they eat and the
same is true for plasma pyruvate which
is the equilibrium with the lactic so
the major substrate for gluconeogenesis
is fully in these animals during the day
and of course being starved they these
animals basically have no glucagon I
mean no insulin so the insulin level is
essentially undetectable in all of these
minds during the day and it goes up in
response to feeding the interesting
thing is glucagon that it so these mice
are hypoglycemic they have low blood
sugar and they're responding to that by
raising glucagon which is the ends of
the hormone that should stimulate
glucose production in the liver and in
fact there's no problem with glucagon
that the knockout mice have just as high
glucagon as the wild-type mice but we
believe that the glucagon is ineffective
because there's no substrate in the form
of lactate and part of it and this is
these are very recent studies but the
first what we decided was well if this
is true then if we simply give these
animals lactate back we should be
to restore the blood sugar so this is
the experiment that was done again this
is the enough these are all knockout
mice and they were calorie restricted
for seven days and then followed during
the day and here's the blood sugar and
you see if the animals were just given
saline injections the blood sugar
declined but if we if they injected
lactate at these different time points
the blood sugar was restored so we're
now going on the hypothesis that the
problem in these mice is that their
muscle is not producing lactic and and
our hypothesis is that the muscle is
actually instead of undergoing
glycolysis and releasing the lactate
that in the absence of growth hormone
the muscle is converting is taking the
pyruvate that it makes and going through
the mitochondria and using oxidative
metabolism and oxidizing the glucose
without releasing lactate so that is and
somehow growth hormone is regulating
that now why do we think that it's
growth hormone that's doing the
regulation let me show you how we
demonstrated that so what we were able
to do is to take an osmotic mini pump
and fill it with either ghrelin or
growth hormone and then and we implanted
this mini pump three days before we
started the calorie restriction so that
we were able to maintain ghrelin levels
at high levels during the calorie
restriction time and this shows the
results in wild-type mice the blood
sugar was stabilized
the increased ghrelin didn't make any
difference however in the goat knockout
mice the blood sugar fell but when they
were infused with ghrelin that fall in
blood sugar was was prevented but you
see here is the growth hormone levels in
wild-type mice the growth hormone was
very high remember this is measured at
five thirty in the afternoon that the
growth hormone level was very high and
there wasn't much further increased with
ghrelin in the knockout mice growth
hormone was low but the ghrelin infusion
allowed it to rise so the hypothesis is
that the actual active principle here is
growth hormone so to test that instead
of infusing ghrelin we infuse growth
hormone and this shows that we got the
same result when we when we infused
growth hormone through the mini pump
here's the knockout mice their blood
sugar is declining during the fasting
period and it's restored when they are
receiving growth hormone these are the
plasma growth hormone levels and again
we gave enough so then wild-type mice
the growth hormone was Elif it was
elevated and in the knockout mice we
reproduce aim growth hormone levels as
we did in the in the wild-type so from
this we conclude that the the action of
ghrelin in maintaining blood sugar
during periods of famine is due to the
ability of ghrelin to release growth
hormone under those conditions and under
those conditions it's the growth hormone
that's maintaining the blood sugar now
the question that professor Lipton asked
his is how to is what is the signal that
turns on grell and secretion and my
esteemed colleague
by saying we don't know and he's right
in the sense that we don't know what
happens during the during the daily
diurnal cycle but we think we do know
what happens during what why ghrelin is
released during this time of fasting and
let me show you the data there so to try
to figure out what it is what is the
signal that's stimulating ghrelin
release it's a difficult problem because
as shown on this slide ghrelin is only
made in a very few cells in the gastric
mucosa and and goat is present in the
same cells but to study the secrete the
regulation of secretion in this very
small population is difficult so to get
around that problem we decided to try
and to be able to work with isolated
cells we decided to try to make grella
nomas to try to make tumors that would
be ghrelin secreting tumors so to do
that we use the technique business I've
been pioneered by Doug hanahan and many
others we we took the pre-pro ghrelin
gene and we introduced the coding region
for the sv40 t antigen and an oncogene
in order to convert the ghrelin cells
into tumor cells and this shows the
stomach of a wild-type mouse and this
shows the stomach of a mouse that's
expressing sv40 t antigen in the grill
in producing cells so these mice develop
Grella nomas and you can tell that by
measuring the plasma ghrelin level so
this is one of the transgenic s 342
antigen mice and or actually an average
of 17 of these mice and what you see is
this progressive massive increase in
plasma ghrelin as these grill
nomas developed and starts secreting
ghrelin we were then able to take these
mice these tumors dissociate the cells
and convert them into cell lines that we
could maintain in cell culture and
therefore study the regulation of
ghrelin secretion in these cultured cell
lines and here you see an experiment in
which we tested a whole bunch of
potential regulators of ghrelin
secretion in these isolated grille and
oma cells by the way i have to explain
why we call these pg1 cells these cells
that mice actually developed tumors in
the pancreas as well as in the stomach
because the pancreas also has some
grillin secreting cells and the first
cell lines that we made came from the
pancreatic tumors so these are these
cells are from the pancreatic tumors but
we get the same result from the stomach
tumors so we added these various
hormones and it turns out that the only
one of the ones that we studied all of
them at super saturating levels the only
one that had a significant effect on
ghrelin secretion was norepinephrine and
so now for the first time in our 40-year
career we're wandering in tube of lip
who it's his territory and what we found
was that if we that we could stimulate
secretion in these cells not only with
epinephrine but with norepinephrine and
in fact that norepinephrine was had a
slightly higher affinity ability to do
this and of course forskolin which is
the activator of analyte cyclase
reproduced the effect of these
energy hormones on the other hand
beta-adrenergic acetylcholine
cholinergic agents did not cause any
stimulation and these are the the
norepinephrine was working at point one
micromolar and epinephrine at point six
micromolar and the slightly higher
affinity for norepinephrine suggests
that the that the that the receptor
that's being activated is the beta-1
adrenergic receptor and in order to test
that possibility we used a specific beta
1 antagonist atenolol and that blocked
this secretion whereas a beta two
antagonists the beta 2 subtype of the
beta-adrenergic receptor had no effect
so we believe that the adrenergic agents
are working through the beta-1
adrenergic receptor and to test that in
intact mice we took two approaches one
is that we depleted catecholamines from
sympathetic nervous nerve endings by use
of the drug were surfing reserpine
prevents the reuptake of catecholamines
in sympathetic neurons and therefore
leads to depletion of catecholamines
from sympathetic neurons and in fact so
in when we looked at plasma ghrelin
levels in animals that were treated only
with vehicle this was the ghrelin level
in the fed state and it went up when the
animals were fasted this was only a 24
hour fast and but when the animals were
surprised and
they're catecholamines were depleted
they that increase was prevented and we
could get the same effect not by
depleting all catecholamines but just by
blocking the beta 1 receptor with
atenolol it prevented this increase
during fasting whereas the the beta two
antagonists did not so so we believe
therefore that this is the metabolic
response to chronic starvation
starvation causes a fall in blood
glucose there's a lot of information
about glucose sensing neurons in the
brain even in the brain itself and in
the in the hypothalamus but it's not
really clear what they were how these
neurons work and what pathways they
affect but somehow the hypoglycemia
leads to activation of the sympathetic
nervous system the sympathetic neurons
in the stomach release norepinephrine
locally and that binds to the beta 1
receptor that stimulates the release of
ghrelin ghrelin goes to the hypothalamus
and the pituitary leads to the
production of growth hormone which then
restores the blood glucose and leads to
survival and when this pathway is
disrupted through by an animal that
can't make ghrelin the blood sugar
continues to fall and this compensatory
mechanism does not occur so we believe
that the answer to the ghrelin puzzle
we're starting from the beginning should
we start all over again just a quick
read yes I guess there's no way no way I
can get in back this is an irreversible
thing but anyway we believe
unfortunately we lost our colleagues to
with the last line but the fact is that
we believe that the reason ghrelin has
been conserved in evolution since
amphibians I mean when you think about
it the problem for survival is not too
much food that's that's a characteristic
you know that's never happened until
very recently but there is all animal
species are constantly threatened by
starvation every every species has gone
through selection based on survival
during periods of famine we believe that
the that ghrelin is essential to
maintaining the blood sugar during
periods of severe famine and that's what
it's essential function is it's very
interesting that in humans the highest
levels of ghrelin are measured in people
with anorexia nervosa these are people
who are essentially dying of starvation
they have very high levels of ghrelin in
their blood and they also have very high
levels of growth hormone and we believe
it's the growth hormone that's
maintaining their blood sugar during
these period of severe weight loss and
malnutrition and it is true that about
fifteen percent of people with anorexia
will die of hypoglycemia and we believe
that's probably because you know there's
a point at which even the ghrelin and
growth hormone camp
maintain your budget can we get back not
too I'm going to get back to the end
okay um so um quick review so that's
what we believe that it was Joe doesn't
like me to use saying we believe he says
it sounds like an evangelical preacher
but john grew up in the south and so he
he's more sensitive to it than i am but
we hypothesize as scientists so there's
the anorexia nervosa and and we believe
we hypothesize ataraxia nervosa people
are being kept alive by their Grella and
the question that we're trying to answer
now is how does how does it work how
does the growth hormone maintain the
blood glucose level during starvation
endocrinologist by the way know that in
infants who are born with primary growth
hormone deficiency one of the big
problems is neonatal hypoglycemia so
it's clear that we need growth hormone
to maintain our blood sugar and and the
question is how does it work and as I
showed you we believe that it has
something to do with actions of growth
hormone on muscle that lead to the
generation of lactate which can then be
used in the classical Corey cycle to
regenerate glucose in the liver now that
we're here I can point out the graduate
student that Joe mentioned jingyang is
the one who persisted who who spend
another six months cloning the last the
16 one of these em boats after the first
15 had failed and in a situation where
he didn't even know that the assay you
know that the cell line that he was
transfecting these we had no evidence
that they
would actually be able to use the goat
enzyme even if it was put in there and
it failed 15 times and and then he
couldn't get the 16th one so he kept
working at it for six months and pieced
it all together I'm saying this for the
students in the audience you know
persistence pays don't give up
and I'd like to call other special
attention to another student from china
tongue jinzhou who worked out this
elaborate protocol for chronic
starvation in mice and is a fantastic
animal experimentalist so with that I
want to thank you and thank dr. alpern
for inviting us and not be happy to
answer questions